i want to start this episode off by just
saying thank you for uh supporting me
and um and just to announce that the
netflix airing
will be on october 19th
so you can check out it on netflix it'll
be there soon i appreciate your love and
support
i appreciate anybody that supported me
in my comedy career
and um
and i'm grateful for you guys to see
this it's been a lot of hard work and a
lot of you guys have come out over the
years and watched me work it and so here
we are
that's october 19th on netflix
get that hitter
i want to thank liquid death for being a
part of my life oh
the irony
i'm going to let everybody know that um
tickets are going on sale now for a show
in coachella california that's right
that's where it is you've heard it it's
a music town coachella california
spotlight 29 casino
and that's uh saturday december 4th 2021
and those tickets available theovon.com
tour
as well we got dates in wilkes-barre pa
minneapolis minnesota charleston
baltimore
burlington
vermont
albany and buffalo new york
are all available theovon.com tour um we
have other places as well but those are
the places that still have tickets
available
the new out of gas
teas collection they got new items on
there theovon.com store check it out if
you'd like to see that
if you've run out of gas a lot like me
then you might want to have something to
wear
while you out there waiting for the
triple-a for the gas friend
today's guest um
he's changing the game up himself other
people have claimed to do it but i
really see it with this man
oh he's a real humorous man and
he's probably one of the
i mean he's just
he's just one of a kind really and he
really is that and uh he's got a special
out to lunch that's available on
youtubes and
he's got his podcast tuesday with
stories
that he co-hosts with mr joe list
i'm happy to have him here today
in our central east studio
mr mark normandy
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
yeah well thank you for uh coming in bro
good to see you man of course of course
good of course good to be here i um
i was just over at um
mark norman ladies and gentlemen
are we on
we're cooking oh boy all right cut that
last thing out
i was just at the dang uh i was over at
uh walgreen
you got walgreen over there in new york
city oh yeah we got a cvs walgreen rite
aid you name it
and they had i was in line and they're
like make sure to tag us on your social
medias and it literally just blew
my brain out of my freaking wiener man
because it was like
who is gonna like you know got my cancer
meds or whatever you know like
yeah
having fun in the parking lot cbs it
just seemed it's just crazy how
everything is like hashtag like just
like it's all connected it's all weird
it's sometimes though you gotta you
gotta admit those guys are funny on
twitter like wendy's will go off on some
guy oh yeah
yeah if wendy's and arby's go off dawg
i'm there for that oh yeah because you
know there's just some fat guy behind a
desk and he's just like ah screw it i'm
gonna be myself
just with the face of wendy's
yeah man wendy's used to be so good oh
the square burger baby dave thomas chili
remember i loved when it was chili was
their thing that was their thing
that was their thing and you get the big
potato you pour the chili on it then
some girl was like what where'd you
learn that then she'd blow you it was it
was a great time yeah and your family
was doing great it's like we're here yes
it felt like you know you go to rallies
or mcdonald's it felt a little low brow
but wendy's felt a little upscale he
kind of jumped out the car yeah like dad
is a good guy oh you know like you'd
have all these crazy vibes yeah i mean
he still hit me but uh
you know i was at the salad bar so i
felt classier
dude i remember two pizza hut salad bars
used to have that pudding on them
all the chocolate pudding yeah that was
big can't believe they did it that's
after little league games it was all
pizza hut all day
oh it was so good man i remember getting
a personal pan you're like jesus christ
my own personal pan i'm doing pretty
good who read two books you know
remember that
yeah they're the book club man we were
smart we'd be in there we were like a
real coupon family oh me too
my mom was that crazy coos with the uh
with the clippings at the end and she's
like hold on i got one you're like come
on you crazy [ __ ] we gotta get we gotta
get out of here
i got a blockbuster i'm ready to yeah no
wonder dad's gone yeah
i couldn't wait around either because
you gotta save six cents on uh you know
some ice cream sandwiches yeah
do you think like people's the
that patience has changed like oh yeah
isn't it it's almost it's almost it's
almost crazy how much it's changing it's
embarrassing like i'll be at a red light
and i'm like i better look at my phone
right i can't make it the eight seconds
before i cross the street i'm like well
i got down time might as well tweet
something yeah
yeah but it's like who's running this
red like is this like you know it's
almost like
you're almost like this red light needs
to get its [ __ ] together kind of it
feels like like um
or just like why you know every little
bit of everything feels like
things didn't used to feel like wasted
time it used to feel like
nice yeah to have some moments i think
that's true yeah well you just didn't
think of it as wasted time i'm just
trying to walk through it it was life it
was just oh yes i'm doing life i'm
outside i'm living yeah and now it's
like wait i could be doing something
this could be a tick tock oh the white
guy's flashing now the hand that could
be a thing yeah i'll put music to it
like what am i doing
we're not living and instagram went down
a couple days ago and there was a part
of me like i hope it doesn't come back
yeah [ __ ] it
yeah you remember that in louisiana i
know growing up a lot of storms coming
through there dude a lot of storms
a lot of people
you know missing teeth a lot of people
missing dna remember they had they had
one guy there they found he didn't have
any dna in his body this was like 14
years old what i missed that guy they
could they couldn't
genome sequence them or something yeah
hopefully he's not a serial killer
because he'll get away with it oh [ __ ]
look if you if god gives you that gift
bro you better buy a hatchet yeah no
doubt about it um
but i remember when the power would go
out at our house dude we would get into
it was like the only time our family was
kind of close yes same with the scrabble
the candles came out you had to talk to
your brother
yeah yeah that was weird
god it was so weird it was so yeah but i
look there's almost something kind of
cool about it like it was a
your family became a little bit of a
necessity because
you were scared kind of yes
you didn't know like
if the second anybody left the candle it
was like what happened
you know true we had to be amish for a
minute yeah yeah and it makes you maybe
the amish are tight
yeah but the armors are pretty tight i
saw some amish at the airport uh yeah
what yeah they're not allowed in there
i think there's a
can amish fly where you looked that up
spencer do you mind i they i think some
of them can fly i don't know if they uh
you might have to be a high school
graduate
i'm not sure what their sense like what
the jurisdiction is on being able to fly
or not yeah
i mean it's all electric so
the amish are not permitted
i'd imagine they can't can you zoom in
on that a little if you can
i think they're all banging each other
by the way
well so they don't need to fly that's
hearsay uh
that's what i've i've been reading in
the uh the amish newsletter we use
trusted english neighbors are not
permitted travel airplanes oh well these
guys must have been
they're rule breakers you know there was
a um i remember that show breaking amish
right yes and there was one of the guys
he's like cutting the grass with that
little
with the just the spinning knife yeah i
remember we had one of those and
they interview him and he's like man i
got i was adopted i'm not even [ __ ]
supposed to be on his dog it was like oh
my god i never saw that one god tlc is
just a
misery channel it's like my 600 pound
life i'm a [ __ ] i'm an amish i'm
getting surgery it's a bummer over there
yeah i wonder why they they really
tapped into that market i guess huh i
don't have any legs someone else has my
legs
you seen that show it's like somebody
took yeah they said they uh it's like
people harvesting organs or something
wow um yeah it's really out on a limb
yeah all right
how's uh
how's comedy in new york right now
what's it like are you in the city i am
i live in manhattan and uh the clubs are
great it's all open you gotta show the
vax card to get in but uh i'll i'll say
this that what isn't the same when i
moved to new york there was all these
hot
bar shows and alternative shows and
those are all gone really i don't think
comics get along anymore
you know comedy's so splintered now you
know you got this group you got that
group and everything's politicized and
what side are you on and all that [ __ ]
and
you know there's like these teams now
and it's it's not good
like when you say team like is it so
it's like does it feel political does it
feel like or just like if you're not
woke enough does it feel i'm just trying
to yeah a little everything little all
that and you got to fall into your tribe
a little bit now i mean the whole
country's going this way so
i don't know
people were different before we all had
our differences but like everybody got
along you made it work there was no
internet as much i mean there was but it
wasn't like
everything because people let all their
[ __ ] out online and then
you don't you don't see people face to
face as much and i think people are just
separating more yeah
yeah i think i started feeling recently
like
you know especially during like a lot of
the i guess election stuff and then
especially during like be when blm
really went off oh yeah because i used
to feel like we're all on the same team
we're all trying to do our best and
everybody
you know
this is what we're doing this is like
america and it's just like how we're you
know we're trying our best
and then i felt like
everything felt like um
some some of the blm stuff to me almost
felt like a like supremacy like it
wasn't like about everybody anymore like
it wasn't and it wasn't even just about
black people it was just like
people wanted to exercise like uh
victimhood
maybe some victimhood but supr it was
just like i don't know everything
started really fragmenting then like
yeah for me i thought oh we're all on
the same team and then it was now like
oh well just it's just about these this
group and this group and right and for
me i think maybe for some people it
didn't it had never been that black
lives mattered or that but for me i
think it always had been so to me i was
just like well i i
i and at some points and this is just me
as a white person right yeah it almost
felt like um
not an attack on me but it felt like
it didn't feel like there was a safe
place for you to go if you were somebody
who's like well i've always
right
right respected everybody like why do i
have to behave any why do i have to like
show a cert be a certain way now or
something i i get what you're saying
yeah it i'm never we grew up in
louisiana you know it was just it was
mixed everywhere was mixed and it i
never even never came across my mind
that black girl didn't matter right so
when everybody's like they mad or you're
like yeah i know and then they get mad
at you for not doing a bunch of [ __ ]
you're like but i've been a good guy the
whole time yeah yeah that was the thing
there was no card to show that you've
been a good guy and there was nobody
that seemed like they wanted to believe
that you'd been a good guy the whole
time yes yes i think that's a human
nature thing they get to yell at you
so they feel better right you know this
this white lady's like hey you're not
doing enough and where's your black
square and you're like
i'm i'm banging a black chick like i
don't know
it's never enough yeah and they that but
that's their own [ __ ] they got some
internal stuff and they want to take it
out on you i think
yeah yeah well i think
i don't know it's just interesting
because
at the same time we've all been really
separated like we've all been in our own
little holes like podcasting has become
like so grateful i'm sure that you oh
yeah that you have uh tuesday the
stories i know just like that everybody
has their own cast it's like at least
you have your own kind of channel now
yep um you got to build your island now
yeah what it does feel like that a
little bit i guess
which i
everybody can have their own thing the
internet is is big and vast and it's got
room for everybody but when people start
attacking
people that's what bugs me yeah you know
like you can have your thing and and
theo can have his thing but when people
come at your thing i'm like why what do
we do that's enough for everybody right
that's bandwidth yeah yeah that's
bandwidth
we got to um
we got a question right here i want to
think i want to think a little bit more
about this i'm not good sometimes some
people are great at thinking and talking
at the same time
when i meet somebody like that like if i
watch like a ben shapiro or like a um
[Music]
uh
jordan peterson somebody who's brain
like it's almost like their mouth is
like a little before their brain that's
impressive it's like a wizard i know
grand wizard i'm the exact opposite i'm
like
my i'm just faking it yeah and then i'm
hoping my brain catches up you know i'll
just keep talking and then maybe it'll
pop in yeah yeah that's how i am too
here's a white guy yeah
[ __ ]
honky theo mark um
i know you guys have similar backgrounds
uh both louisiana boys and both grew up
in uh
primarily black neighborhoods
just curious what was the best part
about being one of the only white kids
in a black neighborhood
gang gang
baby thanks for the question man i
appreciate it definitely the snacks
we had better snacks at our house
did you well we had orange slices and uh
you know
healthy [ __ ]
but do you think that if that that came
from being in a black neighborhood well
just in comparison i'd go to my friend
eddie's house and it was just like uh
[ __ ] i'd never seen before like weird
brands and bags of cereal right like we
had dunkaroos and like a hat full of
heart meat or something yeah
yeah gizzards or whatever the [ __ ] that
is but no but i'm saying what like i
think his question is like what do you
think
was
what was it what was interesting about
it he said what was the one of the perks
of being the one of the white kids
i showed a lot of kids how to skateboard
okay so there you go i think that would
be a real perk so you had better snacks
yeah i think so
so yeah you got to show kids how to
skateboard
i'm trying to think
i had cable i had nintendo
this black kid would come over and play
our nintendo he was unbelievable it was
like something i'd never seen
and me and my brother were like in awe
of this kid he would just
go to town on that nintendo with with
mario he could jump up there when he had
to jump on the flagpole at the end of
mario and slide he could get to the top
oh wow
yeah
yeah that's a lot i think they have
extra muscles in their fingers i think
so that's what i heard anyway did you
hear that growing up in louisiana that
black people have extra muscles in their
body quick twitch they would always say
they got the quick twitch yeah and uh
yeah it was true i mean you try to play
soccer with this one guy in my
neighborhood and i think he was haitian
or something so he was just he was black
and haitian so that's already
yeah i thought that was his name on time
oh yeah entendre we had an alejandra
wilson two at our school
i'm trying to think of some of the
highlights some of the highlights i
remember were that
other white kids at school you knew some
black kids
so it was like you had a little bit more
like my white friend my white friends
didn't really know the black kids oh
that's so you could be like a liaison at
times at least you got a little bit of
like more respect if you were like
talking to the black kid yeah yeah you
could be over there you could kind of
joke around you could have a little bit
more um room with the black kids
um that was the other kid that was on
tantra's brother was liaison
yeah but yeah no you're right you had it
was good to be dip your toe in both
pools you know you knew a little little
of both both cultures
yeah i'm trying to think of what else
other highlights were
yeah you got to be able to joke you got
to
try a little bit more humor on a crowd
that you knew was a little bit
it was a little tougher you got to own i
mean sometimes you got to even you you
didn't get to say the n word i don't
remember what the rules were back then
but you got to like joke around about it
like you just got to be in more circles
people would call you the n-word
that was a great moment oh
yeah
i remember going home and telling my mom
man
she's like don't say it
yeah that was big and also it's weird
because we use the term minority a lot
for certain groups but like in my
neighborhood i was the minority right
you go 10 10 miles this way i'm not but
in my neighborhood i was so i felt like
you got some leeway yeah you were like
you know you ever do an all-black show
and you're the white guy yeah you stand
out you you're the novelty you pop
and uh they would let me pop in this in
this group it feels scary doing an all
black show feels scary
yeah
it's a different it's a different ball
game because uh
i feel like they're more real and they
they kind of will not if you bombing
they're they're fine with letting you
bomb and if you kill they will let you
know you're killing but there's not much
middle gray you never do okay with a
black crowd oh it's interesting
you're the murdering or boo yeah it's
very uh
game of jerome's kind of you know yeah
and that's a weird statement really but
it's like very game of thronesy it's a
coliseum like
coliseum because if not and black people
are always eating at their show yeah so
if not if it's not good they will eat
and you hear that yeah yeah the
silverware
a lot of heavy-handed mamas out there
and they you know some woman two-spoon
and threw some [ __ ] through a damn uh
half a dove or something you know you're
like damn you don't even have a knife
i'm doing horrible right right yeah
that's true and and sometimes there's
jewelry clanking they've got a lot of
crazy jewelry bling i think
i don't know if there's anything tougher
probably than doing
a i don't not tough it definitely if you
had some luck with it then you'd be
fired up
best feeling in the world yeah kill him
for a black room but
it's easy to kill if you play up the
white guy i think if we go up and go i
remember one time i did one in harlem
and they played some rap song to bring
me out and i was like i've never heard
that song before and they're like ah
he's so white
and that was too easy and i remember
going back when i'm not gonna do the
white thing and i bombed yeah so
it was uh i remember i got up one time
and even just said what's up my n words
even on stage oh that's good and they
went nuts man yeah you didn't you said n
word you didn't say the word i said the
real word you said the real word yeah
whoa that's balls this is back when you
could kind of do i don't i mean you
couldn't you weren't supposed but it was
just a moment it's like that's one thing
about comedy though yeah it's like
there's times where it's like if you it
used to be any way if you felt a certain
thing yep
and you could trust that instinct it was
real scary so true it was it was like
somebody [ __ ] it's almost like satan
lit a little fuse in the dish
and you just start to see it freaking
boiling that's so and that would happen
every now and then cause hitting on a
girl is so scary i'm i'm with a lady now
but in the single days
every now and then you get that devil's
spark right in the taint and it would
just work with a girl you had the ball
the confidence and she ate it up and
then sometimes it fell flat but
it's the same thing with comedy every
now and then you get that little twinkle
of jizz in your eye and it just works
yeah
those were good stuff man that was also
before like a hinchcliffe day you know
no one had a phone out so you were
saying that was like a magic thing in
the in the moment that's that's the
point
that's the point you used to be able to
ride the moment yes and now
the moment isn't there no no no the
moment is to be something that is to be
either
monetized later
or
judged later yep or the moment is uh the
moment doesn't exist right that's true
like the value of it or i don't know
what is it i'm trying to think about it
i know exactly what you mean there was a
a weird spark in the air between you and
this group at that time yeah and then
it's gone
and that's really what comedy was kind
of i know
yeah bill bird talked about he went to
that chapel compound and he said
all the phones are locked up and he just
said crazy [ __ ] and he forgot like oh
this is what it used to be wow and it
hit him you know like how much stand-up
has changed and how it's all video and
daniel tosh makes a joke it's on the
news you know and
that's not supposed to be it's supposed
to be in a basement and just
right here right now yeah dude i
remember
john mayer one time
who
uh
who's so talented he like um he's like
his brain is like a brain i'm way
jealous of really yeah he just has that
like
i mean it's like uh he just has a just a
gifted
he's gifted in that freaking top sack
you know what i'm saying but he um
he got on stage one night at the comedy
store right and he did some jokes and it
was good it was good stuff it was smart
and it's him you got to hear his voice
you got to hear him think like kind of
see how he thinks a little
and then
i want to say it was a few days later
oh he talked about on stage he goes it's
interesting because i can talk about
things tonight but it's but i can't
really talk about things he's like
because i make a joke tonight something
in this moment
three days from now i'm having a
sandwich with my mom somewhere two weeks
from now
um sitting down to dinner with a friend
and this is gonna pop up on something's
gonna pop up on tmz and they're gonna
have framed it how they want and it's
going to ruin that moment for me
completely um and i just i just
remembered i remembered also just
thinking what it was like if you were
already so famous in one thing that you
couldn't even try something else i know
and the the crazy thing is
everybody loves the moment everybody
wants the moment but a couple of queefs
have to ruin it for everything and now
we can't have these moments yeah queef
latina dude yeah
that was my improv group in college
no no i'm just kidding but uh it's true
that's the name of the app right there
yeah it is here
look look real facts the holidays coming
up pumpkin time coming up everybody
coming up coming up
back it up back it up
what i'm talking about is ship station
baby you want to get rid of something
you're selling wreaths
you're selling christmas wreaths baby
reefs baby combs
that's the new thing every baby needs a
comb you see a baby without a comb he
said damn how he gonna really
stay quaffed as he ages
yep between growing your business
managing inventory and juggling orders
you got a lot going on this holiday
season
make shipping uh
the easiest part of your day was ship
station
look i've used ship station man if you
want to ship something ship ship ship
ship station ship it the easy use the
money you save is save the money make it
easy why you messing around you got all
this tape you hit your mom's house
taping up a damn box
and you ain't even got you on the uber
over there damn you do you screwing
around
that's right
easy to import orders from any sales
channel
that's right use ups usps all the
carriers
they do it all to never too early to
start prepping for the holiday rush so
get a head start with ship station
my listeners can use the offer code theo
to get that 60 day free trial that'll
get you almost through the holidays yep
do it learn it it's two months of stress
free holiday shipping that's it just go
to ship shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter code t-h-e-o
shipstation.com make ship happen
autumn's in the air pumpkins in the
patch you know it these pumpkins are
patching fam
i saw a pumpkin the other day with an
eye patch on i said dang they going they
doing
that's what i'm telling you about
manscape
it's holiday season get that get that
get trim that hair off your front arm
homie
that's right make sure you're keeping
things fresh this fall
get it right what if your mother walks
in on you and you're naked
you want to look well
yep i've uh recently trimmed up my
crotch and body and i'm happy to do it
and i enjoy doing it
manscaped
they're offering it all right now
join the two million men worldwide using
manscaped by going to manscape.com theo
for 20 off and free shipping
it's the fourth generation performance
package
man there's no other way to do it
there really is no other way to do it
go to manscape.com theo for 20 off and
free shipping that's manscaped.com
t-h-e-o for 20 off and free shipping
support this damn podcast
and do well by yourself
your granddaddy's getting old get him
that tremor man trim his old ass up
you want him looking shorn for the lord
don't you
treat each other well
yeah but it everybody likes the moment
but a couple of people i keep ruining
[ __ ]
it's funny it's funny do we do we
it's interesting to think about because
i never really squared it down to that's
what it is that's what's not available
that's what's not
the mo it's just not um
man i can't understand i can't
understand what i'm trying to say i know
what you mean i'm trying to be
supportive i think that yeah these
youtube videos these youtube specials
are so cool because it feels kind of
like real i know you're doing a netflix
congrats
well i'm envious though honestly because
you're because you're youtube i was
talking to your agent a couple of weeks
ago actually oh really yeah and he loves
you absolutely yeah and he should but
the one thing we were talking about was
he mentioned that um
he said well you know what's really
happening right now
is mark norman's special is really
popping
and i think that was a br he'd never
used that word before and i could tell
when he said it
uh but anyway he said no he was just
really like you know he said it's really
doing something for him i mean i even
noticed you're adding so you're adding
afternoon shows yeah yeah that felt good
do you feel like this is something um
that has this has been like a real mover
of of the sticks for you uh the youtube
the youtube special 100 game changer i
mean i couldn't get a thing cooking
nobody would have me and then i put that
out and it did well and people were like
oh who's this guy i'm like i'm the same
[ __ ] guy that's the special i tried
to give you
hbo or or oxygen or whoever and uh they
all said no dice
[ __ ] and then you put it on youtube
and they're all in
and now do they want to buy i don't know
if they've been actually well i guess
it's already out but has there been now
there's talk of like what's the next
thing and i'm like god sucks some some
people have just proved themselves where
other people just get [ __ ] oh yeah but
that's judaism you're talking about but
we're not saying that but yeah but it's
obviously it's written down somewhere
but um but no i agree with you man it's
like uh but then also it's like
i used to think that way man and i think
sometimes i still probably do but um
but then it's like i noticed i used to
want stuff
when i wasn't really ready for it oh
well that's that's every comic
we want it all yeah you're like four
years in dude you're you're like going
on you're like going first on a show
that bill burr is supposed to pop in at
and you're just like [ __ ] man i should
be where he is oh yes valenzuela was our
dad's name richie
you know like you're out there just
[ __ ] you're quoting la bamba like
you're into it yeah
uh but it's not true and then it all
happens when it's kind of supposed to
happen i think um i agree yeah and
that's that's the everybody goes what
advice do you have the young comics it's
no you suck no you're not ready you
think you're ready but you're not and
get better yeah because you think you're
there but you're not there it's like
when the fat guy goes i should be
[ __ ] heidi klum and you're like why
would she [ __ ] you yeah but
you got to get there yeah you got to get
there you got to get outdoors you got to
walk you got to get your breathing up
you got to really you gotta change that
shirt yeah you know yeah yeah um
but that's crazy you're adding shows now
has this happened before i mean i know
it's i know it's been kind of happening
but like has it been like like what have
you noticed what has been some things
that have been different uh well the
social media goes up and then
people it's almost like high school
where you no one really talked to you
then you get a cool car and they're kind
of like hey well come eat lunch with us
there yeah and i'm like oh wow okay and
it's nice but you gotta that's what's
cool about stand-up or any art form i
guess is uh you gotta stay funny you
gotta stay good you know you can't just
join the cool kid table and then just
not chain you gotta still keep
progressing i think right it's a
meritocracy kind of what does that mean
what does it mean a meritocracy like
good quality stuff
wins instead of just being the hot guy
the popular guy it's actually
you know like sports or a meritocracy
that the guy who made the most
touchdowns they win right you know yeah
i remember being real jealous er like
when i was doing comedy earlier of
certain guys
and be like man they and then it's like
now it's like i'm grateful to be where
i'm at yeah um you got to be grateful
because how many of those
e true hollywood mtv unplugged where
they go i i'm a millionaire i live in a
mansion i'm banging a supermodel uh my
kid is in the honor roll and they're
still miserable yeah so you gotta
everything
the fact that i sold out these shows and
i'm adding shows i'm like oh my god i'm
happy here for the rest of my life this
is great i never thought i'd be here
that's cool man you gotta be grateful
yeah it's so deserved for you too man
you've always been like the funniest guy
oh i don't know about that
have you seen uh earthquake
actually due to earthquake kills beast
kills some of the guys i never want to
follow i'll name them yeah
andrew schultz the first time i saw him
i was like i never want to follow that
guy he can really own a room that yeah
he's got he's on he's on the stool and
they're just sitting on every word he's
saying yeah and i haven't seen him in a
few years this was like when he was this
before he broke you know before he was
like getting real popular yeah um
but uh
but earthquake was one oh yeah and um
chris d'alia was a relationship sure
that's what i really follow god it was
hard and di stefano is really hard to
find so funny so funny um and also it's
just it's different like how it flows
kind of um
so the have you set your youtube into
clips as well have you put in your clips
okay you got to have the clips yeah the
clips are bite-sized they bring people
in they go what's this from then they
watch the whole thing or
and you know how it is they say social
media is like an iv drip you just got to
keep going yeah you want to take the day
off but put something else up and you
own it you own your special oh yeah
see that's what makes me mad
it really does
really you can do it you could do one
tomorrow
uh maybe in a year maybe in like six
months i could i got to get some more
material but yes there's no money in it
right but so well let's say you have i
think are you are you getting close to
10 million on there eight million seven
and a half okay yeah so we're getting
there what do you what do you make on 10
million views do you think well
accumulated you get a check every month
so depending on the month it might be a
thousand might be three thousand so i've
already made cause comedy central
wouldn't take it and they pay 30 grand
really and i've already gone way beyond
that so i was crushed when they didn't
buy it but now i'm like [ __ ] you i've
made more and i own it yeah blow me cece
also yeah also [ __ ] them yeah
what did schumer used to say she used to
always say since we're both right here
right now
you could give comedy central a gold
brick and they would bronze it oh
that's good that's what she used to say
i think she stiffed him for the last
year of her show i think i think so i
think she was [ __ ] supposed to yeah
she's got balls
dude she's got some freaking hard balls
on the top two nice ones huh you banged
her i mean i don't know about that but i
mean i definitely
we i i you know i i have i knew her well
at sure at a certain point yeah she's a
good we got a real beetle crawling on
the ceiling here watch out everybody can
we get a shot of that spence yeah yeah
maybe get it with your phone at least
spencer or whatever just get it from
there if you don't mind
i want to be honest about everything
that happens in here i like it i respect
them i like the between two ferns too
you gotta and you got the uh impeachment
curtain behind you oh yeah definitely
this is impeachment
[Music]
this is definitely like if they had a
civil war draft room
yes like if norv turner were freaking
picking infantrymen this would be it
though
like if frederick douglass was putting
together his fantasy team right dude i
used to have these dreams that i was
doing uh undercover boss right but
during slavery right so i'd have these
dreams that's a great sketch oh
it was snl's gonna steal that one
i'd be like hey woody we get do we have
to work today guys and somebody would be
like no and i'd like write it down
like i just remember having these crazy
dreams and lilac was my name lilac
that's nice
yeah tuskegee that was something pretty
good the airman yes
man you ever think about war
i don't know if we could do it
i mean we could go out there and [ __ ] in
a hole and peel potatoes and do some
push-ups but
in those trenches with a machine gun
bullets whizzing
those guys were tough
yeah you know what's left a lot of our
what's left us has really been that a
lot of that toughness yeah because life
was precious it was flimsy like you
might get drafted you're 18 19. you
might go off to germany and and die and
never come back yeah polio every i mean
there's just so many things it was like
everything was life and death the
[ __ ] the the bombs with russia with
this with the alarms going off you had
to get under your desk and now we're
worried about latinx
you know like we have so few problems we
got to focus on uh
what's that pronoun you know yeah you
gotta make up stuff oh somebody dropped
a her over there i heard
yeah yeah back then it was like we might
die tomorrow
yeah i think i miss like uh
it just used to be different and i don't
know if i don't know
i just don't even you almost feel like
such a um
pawn now even if you don't want to i
feel like do you ever feel like that
pawn who's just a pawn not even and just
in like a lot of it is this electronica
just how much it's like you know
people are like i don't want to be
tracked you know i don't want a website
but then like they'll be at the cvs and
enter their phone number to get like
six percent it's just like
there's no escaping
the machine yeah we're all in it
it's scary you know people have an
iphone they go i can't get this they'll
track me i'm like you got an iphone they
got your gps they got your satellite
right there yeah you fought your father
we're all in it and you can't not be in
it
right that's the thing you can't not be
in they they're good they got us by the
balls these guys they got spotted short
and curly and do you think they are a
real group do you think this is like i
think where a lot of people you either
you either go in this way or you owe in
benjamin you know it's like who has a
new documentary out too is that right
yep and i do want to support it and uh
he sent me a link to it man and it is
really interesting interesting he sent
me a link you know and um
and i literally watched 40 minutes of it
damn that's pretty good 40 minutes is
tough nowadays
yeah i mean we got squid game to get
after you know oh
i'm in the last episode and i can't even
get hard anymore
your dick's a squid oh yeah that's
killing me man i'm about to blow ink out
of it
um but yeah yeah i think well i think
this is the scary part i don't want to
get all conspiracy uh alex jones qe on
you but no it's interesting something
feels weird something's weird suicide is
up anxiety anxiety's up depression's up
it's the corporations and those used to
be your thing you know
yeah right
yeah now everybody's doing it but
the corporations are winning that's kind
of the new religion that's kind of the
we talk about biden and the president
it's all the corporate they're the ones
in power oh yeah so
i forgot my point but
their
suicide is up so we talk about how we we
care about mental health we care about
people's lives but if the corporations
are making money i think that'll just
win yeah that'll beat no one will care
about the kids killing themselves if the
corporations are still thriving yeah
they don't pay taxes it's crazy
this is the whole system is crazy you
can't help but start to feel i think i
it used to feel like being human meant a
little more i think yo yeah wait now
we've got two bugs that are meeting and
there's one over there too holy hell
and we just got it sprayed in here
didn't we
damn did the spraying we gotta fire that
guy
man wow
if these guys uh start [ __ ] that one
definitely
oh boy
oh if they if they do sex man
then this is going to be pretty good
yeah let's go for it we don't have to i
mean yeah we don't have it on tape but
i'll get off
we got to get a uh we'll just we could
edit we could find something yeah we'll
edit it in but are they about to meet up
yeah i think so this is a hot date they
gotta get a release for them if they're
gonna [ __ ]
this a drug deal
oh damn yeah that was a handoff if i've
ever seen it sure was huh somebody
caught that fentanyl and just hit the
road jack
well if it is fentanyl then you don't
have to worry about the exterminator
because they'll be dead yeah hopefully
it is man yeah fentanyl is not everybody
yeah it's just weird man you can't even
do coke it's just everything feels
tainted a little bit yeah it's kooky
times man
do you do you really feel like sometimes
i can't feel it's like am i just alone
and feeling that way does everybody feel
like things seem weird i think we do
because we're a little older now yeah
and uh i think young people just grew up
with this [ __ ] and there's it's normal
but right we i saw a day before uh you
know pornhub yeah and it might have been
a better time
but then that then do i think do i sound
like the old guy who's like oh you're
out of touch man i'm like maybe i am out
of touch but
i don't know life felt more normal
before we're too tuned in we're we know
all the news story i know everything
about the taliban
i can
see anal gaping and i can buy socks in
one sitting yeah it's a lot
yeah it is a lot it's too there's no
the imaginati i don't know that my
imagination barely even works anymore oh
yeah that's out i used to use it to jerk
off oh yeah forget about that now that's
over dude that's a great point
think about using your imagination dude
i remember getting a set of pins like
colorful pens one time for christmas or
something
birthday or christmas
and dude somebody give me a little this
dude nikki at our school would draw a
piece piece of cooter for you for the
weekend right two dollars wow this kid
could bro the labia and everything
majora menorah oh dude the freaking evil
angora dog he had all of it in there
well he had the freaking uh i mean you
had the freaking uh orion's belt do you
hear all this thing dude big clitter
some healthy ladies in there yeah yeah
sure yeah yeah so
there was a lot of good stuff going on
in there he sketched that for you for
two bucks yeah you have that thing for
the weekend it was like having a girl
you know right and i'm gonna get my own
set of pins and duplicating his thing
one time ah
and kind of having my own deal but that
yeah you just used to have your
imagination i remember like drawing tits
on a pillow and just
calling it katie you know and then you
put your face right in there
fluff that pillow and that was my pillow
yeah those were the days my friend drew
women too and again it's like the amish
porn but
remember even in a car ride you'd play
20 questions or punch buggy you had to
make fun right and now you don't have to
make fun because everybody's on their
phone
and everybody's on their phone just
doing the same things it's all just
whatever someone who owns whatever the
little
template is it's just there's no there's
not a lot of even diversity of thought
it's like everybody's getting these ads
for untucked shirts right
right yeah
everybody's girlfriend will get them one
for christmas and think it's cute it
just start
but i do wonder is that just getting
older and that every generation thinks
that i know exactly these kids with
their beatles music and all that and
their televisions and their eight tracks
like are we those guys now or is this
actually
a problem right it's hard it's hard to
know
and if you are if you are like 18 or
something you don't know it's a problem
anyway you don't know you don't know any
difference just normal
yeah
yeah it's tough we need to get like a
little tween in here and ask him well
trevor wallace is a he's a oh he's mid
20s phenom oh he's phenomenal he's so
he's so funny great dude he's a cute
twink but he uh oh you take him too you
take him to a gay area where men with
money
bidding war you got that right oh
i mean he is adorable oh he is
definitely areas right there look at him
oh
come on not of hair out of place he
looks all german
cute he's jewish too i think what
wow
baby
but he could be anything the guy's so
hilarious gonna unfollow him now but
yeah he could be anything but here's one
thing i was interesting one night uh he
was talking and
he said
dude he's like movies man like they're
so long yes and i was like what do you
mean he's like but me and my friends we
can't sit through a movie like it seems
insane wild and you can't blame them
no but when it rained outside you popped
that vhs and you watched roger rabbit
and you loved it and there were no
interruptions nothing could interrupt
you it was like maybe the phone would
ring once right right
there was no fentanyl in the film there
was no
you weren't going to get a text message
it was a different time it was a
different time i'll try to show my girl
she's younger than me
oh it's nice is it hard though to not
make mistakes and say things that make
you sound old oh all the time i'm just
giving up i'm the old guy i can't get it
up but uh
i mean she can't i'll be like you got to
watch jaws she's like this is the most
boring thing i've ever seen i'm like
this was a huge move it's a classic she
said i can't do it
godfather forget about it yeah
she's she's watching tick tock and then
she'll wait for something to happen in
jaws yes and then she'll go back to tick
tock when they're when they're just
swimming on the beach
so yeah it's almost like they're it's
just yeah
it's tough man if you'd go on a date
with a younger girl i went on a date and
i she said well what music put on some
music i was like all right cool just
and i used apple music and she's like
how old are you ah
that's old now
that's old i was impressed with apple me
too but i think it's spotify i mean i
think it's just spotify oh damn you know
i don't i don't even like
yeah [ __ ]
i've been using a napster
yeah
yeah yeah
i haven't said that word in 25 years by
the way that came right out of my
[ __ ] with cobwebs on it
remember napster that was big remember
zillow or no not zillow uh
there was one with a z
[ __ ] it was green and it came with all
kinds of viruses
oh
damn maybe it wasn't a z uh
that was
current
oh yeah
lime
no lime wire lime wire that was
something yeah what was that
that was like napster
that was big remember you're like oh my
god i found oasis
on here yeah
it would take you four hours you finally
found wonder wall for free
and you already owned it and it took a
week to download it
napster wonder whatever happened to the
napster guy he would be a great guest on
a podcast oh yeah and is he rich is he
living under a bridge is he suicidal
what's going on yeah
yeah yeah i remember watching looking at
porn and my friend was like we should
print it out so he used all his dad's
printed ring and he was going right
right and then we printed out and we'd
have to peel that [ __ ] holes off the
side you know
perforated or whatever and i would keep
it in my pocket and i remember mowing
the lawn at my grandmother's house and
every now and then i'd go
all right
and then it would go back to mowing
along still got it still got it god
do you notice your ego changing any as
you get a little bit more clown of like
dude and because ego is a weird thing
ego is like a thing that happens without
our even
it's this crazy monkey that lives inside
of you totally you know do you notice
yourself do you have any like kind of
moments where you like you start to
notice your own behaviors changing or
not you may not it's a great question i
i think with some comics like the the
guy inside you the little gnome that
lives inside you he's such a loser and
an insecure dweeb that i'll never be
able to
be
like chappelle you can tell he kind of
knows he's hot [ __ ]
and uh i think what changed for me is
the comfort you know you go hey i flew
this this level delta comfort it's tough
to go back yeah you know or you ever
have this one this might have been an la
thing but you do the road you're killing
in some club you're sold out all your
people are there gang gang they love you
and then you go to some club to do 10
minutes in la or or here and they're
kind of like ah that wasn't bad you're
like well i've been murdering all week
but they love you they know you and then
here they're just another comic yeah
so that's a good check
yes yeah i agree that's one good thing
about comedy is that there's with uh
with the fact that you have to keep
practicing that there's those checks you
know yeah um you need it
some things do get a little more
comfortable but i do think you deserve
it as a comedian like being able to fly
first class or something it's like at a
certain point it's just like
or flying the same airlines you're able
to get the miles and do it that way yes
that's one thing bert chrysler told me a
long time ago he's like just fly one
airline i promise you just fly the same
airline i know but i'm such a
cum-guzzler that i'm like well the
spirit's 11 cents cheaper so maybe i'll
go with that and then you you're sitting
on wicker yeah yeah brutal you're eating
uh yeah and you just met her
you know
yeah yeah
yeah um yeah it's a it's a black girl
that wants to be it's a white girl that
wants to be black that also wants to be
outdoor furniture
exactly i saw two dogs fight on a spirit
airline
and i heard the beef in the line when
they were doing the check-in ticketing
you could see little they you know you
could see them beefing a little and then
they [ __ ] let them loose and they
were video i almost think they did it
for like a tick tock oh that's a great
tick tock and michael vicks uh cheering
him on yeah but that's that just shows
that service dogs are [ __ ] there's
supposed to be like anxiety and all this
but like if we got two of them fighting
that just increases the anxiety
oh yeah this one was definitely one of
them was really white kind of
like lean but
confident it kind of like uh
jack shore i don't know if you're
familiar with him he's a ufc guy but no
i don't know jack i like ufc but i don't
know sure
what's the difference between a little
interracial uh there he is right there
good morning i don't know jack sure he
just actually he sent me a jersey i
should have uh i should have worn it
i'll wear it next time what do you know
about this patty patty pimento oh yeah
daddy pemberton he's like the beatles
little freaking he's like if any of the
beatles look good it would be him
dude whoa the beatles were not
attractive
they're british queefs i mean they're
they're ugly they're like working-class
uh bqs yeah oh there he is pemberton
yeah he's he's he's the guy popping
right now is he gonna be all right
there he is oh yeah
look at him he looks like if you look at
that one pitcher next to bisping and on
the third row the third pitcher yeah he
looks like a cabbage patch kid dude
who [ __ ] is finally getting revenge
for all the people just hugging him and
pissing on him at night
oh i know i pissed off mine and the
wrestling buddies oh yeah
see this shows that like confidence and
being
like
just self-assured goes a long way the
guy's got weird hair he's a little guy
he's got blue eyes he's pale but he
looks he seems cool he owns it
well it's that whole six nine vibe it's
that whole thing of like if i can be
confident enough and just say [ __ ] you
here i am yeah then i can win but i
wonder does that work for everyone
good question that's what i wonder yeah
i don't know i don't know like ted bundy
they say
he was so handsome so confident he was
picking up all these gals in the 70s and
he did card tricks too you know that
what
i did not know that like crazy to hit on
a girl yeah
not a bad idea
but you wouldn't think that a murderer
would be doing card tricks i feel like
it seems like the total
i'm sure like other murderers like oh
look at this [ __ ] yeah you know right
look at this magician i know oh he uses
magic to murder uh
prop guy yeah i think though
i think women will not admit it but
they're turned on by magicians
they won't admit it but i think ladies
are like oh that david blaine i'll tell
you
urbanista
that's something i'm telling you about
today it's about
you know you want the look and feel of
city life you want the look and feel of
of a real
culture
when you're wearing headphones
and that's urbanista sleek wireless
earbuds with a new and improved dual mic
for an immersive clear
audio experience
yup
its active noise canceling reduces
unwanted sound with a superior precision
while the new ambient sound mode
will uh enforce and define outside
voices without the need to lower the
volume or hit pause it's basically the
the most enlightened folks you know have
created headphones
this out of stockholm
sweden europe
2010 they made these bad they made this
bad batch and i love them jeepers i put
them on i feel like i'm in
if i'm listening to the blues i feel
like i'm listening to them in memphis
if i'm listening to some soul i feel
like i'm listening to it in new orleans
and that's what urbanista does
it's just their couture of the actual
headphones and earbuds
it's unprecedented right now urban east
has a special offer for tpw listeners go
to urbanista.com
theo
get 20 off your entire order that's the
whole batch
20 off everything you'll even get free
shipping
for all orders over sixty dollars go to
urbanista.com theo for 20 off that's
urbanista.com
theo
for many people in the u.s of america
concerned about the cost of health
insurance there are no good options
there's none
zilcho
but crowd health is a community of
people who are tired of paying for a
broken system
yep it's a place where you can get a
simple flexible and affordable way to
pay for your health care
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members
for a limited time our listeners get
their first month free
and after you've been a member crowd
health will include a fitness wearable
that's 30 days
to try risk-free plus the fitness
wearable just go to crowdhealth.com
fit
and enter code theo at sign up enter
that code baby you want to get that
crowd health you want everybody helping
you breathing into your lungs you want
that cpr
you want that damn uh
heimlich
you want it all
and that's crowdhealth.com
fit
promo code theo yup crowdhealth is not
health insurance it's a
community-powered alternative terms and
conditions apply if you're sick of big
health insurance
and the bs that goes with it
go to crowd health
go to join crowdhealth.com fit and enter
code theo learn about it crowd health
i yeah i wonder what i think cause when
i think that falls in
with the thing that women wants to be
murdered really ah i think you got
something there
my lady loves all that murder um like
fake
you know hold you down and put a ski
mask on and yeah all that [ __ ]
brian laundry all that stuff with that
man they're looking for that everybody
all these chicks want to bang that guy
yeah so it's a weird fetish these ladies
that it's also all murder all the time
they love murder do you think that and
also we're not gonna have any good
murderers anymore that's done i mean you
can even see
that's i mean it's just too much digital
footprint yeah i just can't believe
laundry's still on the lamb even with
dog the the n-word bounty hunter on his
tail
and he's still out there he might be
dead in a ravine for all i know i don't
know i think if you've gone that long
i feel like you keep riding it out cause
you've already
you've already killed yeah you've
already been hiding for a month or two
like i think at that point
if you haven't turned yourself in or
taking your life after a couple weeks i
feel like you've got you've gotten into
that you're in vanderslut kind of vibe
where you're like
what can i do what else yes can i god
how long can i hide what
and it's almost seems
exciting
uh yeah it's definitely life and death
it's dark but if you imagine waking up
in the morning and you or somebody that
is untraceable yeah
you nobody can locate you
here's what it seems it seems relaxing
you think so i would be on edge
constantly i feel like at least you're
like you're you're not on your phone
you're at least spending time like out
in nature probably i feel like you're
doing the things that a lot of us need
to do if he didn't do the murder i would
say
he could be like a homeopath or
something right right he could open up a
thing in maui
yeah like a cbd shop or some [ __ ]
yeah he's probably sitting at a bar
somewhere in oklahoma
with a mustache and shades on drinking a
beer and going oh [ __ ] i'm on the news
yeah you know and he's i bet he's
milking it like how about this [ __ ]
psycho huh and the guy next time's like
i know right
hope they catch that guy's like yeah
[ __ ] him probably enjoying it
and halloween he gets to come party too
right he can dress up
every day is halloween for him yeah
but to be able to one night come down
from the hills and frickin let it loose
do jager bombs with a freaking mime
right
right you know just come down and just
party dude
piss on a mummy just have fun man
halloween was fun um
we got some other good questions what's
something else that popped in here
spence
this one
this guy's a hunk
would it be great
theodore
what's up fellas hey hey this is alex
from birmingham big l i am just sitting
outside
listening to the rain because i work
from home now and that's pretty much the
excitement of my day but uh
question for mark i was just watching
the
uh chrissy chaos episode that you were
on about five or six months ago and you
were talking about
uh your seinfeld story
um how you were opening up for him and
then covet hit and
i was just curious what the status of
y'all's current relationship is have you
heard from him in the last five or six
months are you going to be working with
him again
in the future
uh just curious about that i'm also a
big seinfeld fan so
gang gang theo i love you
uh y'all keep doing your thing man
gang baby love you too brother thank you
people love you
people love you ah not my dad
but
either way
uh the seinfeld thing is crazy because
uh
i was a huge fan i watched it with my
parents growing up and then now to have
his phone number is his bananas yeah
but uh it's almost like the hot girl i
open for him one weekend we did four
shows we went out after i had wine had
pizza tiramisu best night of my life
and
coveted hit so then everything got weird
and then i kept trying to text him it's
like a girl you [ __ ] once that you're
in love with but yeah the relationship
just kind of distancing but you try to
keep it going with a text but
it's inevitable it's not going to last
but uh i'll text him every now and then
and he'll get back to me so i'll take it
yeah
i talked about norm dying and he was he
had some cool [ __ ] to say that's cool
yeah so
i hate to say it but sometimes an event
happens like that you're like oh this is
a good opportunity to text the big jew
yeah you got to go bj on that dude
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's interesting
how like if you get a somebody's number
that's a celebrity or that's popular to
you yeah then like how nervous you feel
like and then you also start to
recognize how like their lives are so
busy that they just
it's not that they don't care anything
about you the friendship just picks back
up kind of when you see each other again
there's just not as much down time to
communicate like yeah completely there's
just not as much free time as when you
were just
chilling and you [ __ ] just didn't
have anything to do yeah yeah and he's a
little older so he's not part of that
text general like we'll just text back
and forth and he's
i think he takes a while to get back to
you you know he's a thinker also
that's true
so i'm just happy because you know how
much power i have just having his i
could give that out i could call him
drunk i mean i could do so many bad
things so i'm really trying to be a good
good little boy with his number number
shepard yes exactly yeah and sometimes
you like have all the numbers and then
you get drunk and lose one one one runs
down the hill oh there's a six yeah yeah
i hope no one knows anything yeah right
i texted him once drunk and i ha i never
did it again because he his reaction was
kind of like i could tell it was weird
he was weirded out
but he's cool he's so normal he's like
us you know you talk to him you're like
oh you're just a dude yeah and we put
him up on this uh weird pedestal but
he's just like us yeah he's just busier
and richer
yeah and that's so real i mean i think
at a certain level of
i think have you noticed anything
different about yourself about making
money if you started to think anything
differently or
do you notice anything different i'm
screw up so kind of poor that it's kind
of baked into me but i'm trying to uh
you enjoy the money a little more yeah
well you get yourself something we get
you a little something maybe an extra
you know thing of socks or something
yeah yeah do a skiing trip or you guys
are like is there something nice you're
gonna do that you kind of are doing yeah
me and the lady will go on trips which i
never did i was like trips that's for
you know rockefellers yeah but she's
like no we we should go and i and i need
her it's kind of a yin and yang a little
andrew yang and we can go do [ __ ]
because she'll push me to do it right
and i i need that cause it's all
coupons in here yeah yeah yeah you got
that coupon heart yeah exactly yeah
you got 40 off aorta's in there yeah
right
but i'm noticing i go to your house or
nate's house or uh tim dillon's house or
something like that and you're like all
right all right i gotta start
enjoying my [ __ ] well also i live in a
place where houses are affordable you
know you could it's like
nate and i live in a place where house
you know
if you go to my apartment in la it's as
big as this you know two of these rooms
oh okay so so it's always interesting
for me because i go from having a house
here which is it's a nice home to going
back to my apartment which is just
totally it's a nice apartment yeah you
know it's a it's a beautiful apartment
um
but it's like uh it's funny because i'll
kind of
it's funny because i almost sometimes
fit easier into that like i know i hate
being in a place where those i feel like
extra space that i can't use it all yes
dude i remember the first night i ever
stayed at like an expensive hotel room
dude like a suite with two rooms yeah
yeah dude i still was like if i go to
bed i'm wasting the money yes yes it's
like in castaway where he's laying on
the couch and keeps flicking the light
on you don't know what to do with all
this this technology in the space it's
weird
yeah so i just stayed up i was like at
least i might as well stay awake and get
the money's worth
yeah i'm [ __ ] exhausted the next day
but like feeling like i [ __ ] got my
value you know yeah i'll tell you what
where money is good everybody thinks
i'll buy a lamborghini and i'll buy a
mansion and i'll buy an escort or
whatever an ipad
the money is good for little things that
like
okay let's say
you go to the airport and your flight's
delayed and you're like ah [ __ ] i'm just
sitting here for like another six hours
now then you can go to the sit-down
place at the airport the restaurant and
actually enjoy a meal right and not not
stress over it for six weeks right that
part's nice we're little things we can
just like oh i'll just buy this and not
think about it i forgot my hoodie i'll
go buy one right little things like that
yeah that is you know what that's about
that that's a great point because i
don't think i'd ever get myself anything
fancy like i got a four ranger truck
like right i and you know i just don't
think
i don't know i just don't think i could
fit into it well
same but then the problem is we might
have kids that end up having money dude
then i'm gonna [ __ ] hate them that's
true that's true kids need a little
struggle nothing worse than a rich kid
oh nightmare
sometimes a lot of times anyway
sometimes it's somebody that breaks the
norm that's true
but also the rich was my arch nemesis
always it still is kind of like some
people would be like well you make some
money and i was like but i'll never be
rich dude rich is also an attitude it's
an attitude yeah i don't have that
either you know it's like my dad's gonna
bail me out right right yeah do you know
my father is he start throwing money at
people and [ __ ] yeah i don't have any of
that yeah like my dad has liver spots on
his arms okay
so he ain't bailing anybody out of
anything dude you know and he's drunk
right now and he [ __ ] is the one that
drove me over here so
my dad has the mismatch suit you know
the blazer don't match it's like like a
dark blue and then like a like a gray up
top it's bad
dude
my dad would get so drunk dude he
wouldn't would dry i guess he would
drive home and just kind of crash his
car we had like this kind of like
really sh like
slow like the gradient was real
it was a real like not a heavy gradient
getting into the bottom of this ditch so
he would just kind of ease his car right
into the bottom of it oh yeah yeah i can
just finish out the night
when i did you ever go tubing and yeah
we went that was a big deal uh we'd go
too big where would you guys go in north
of covington when you guys go like uh if
you said it i'd know it
on the bogafalaya
pocafellaia something like that
bogachitta that was it bogachitta yeah
we'd go there all the time and uh one
time i was with a girl yeah dating a
girl
and
this is a crazy story we got of course
you just drink all day on a tube just
floating in the sun we had sex on a sand
bar yeah i've been there yes yeah dude
and there it is right there there it is
yes so and you remember you go on a
school bus and they give you the tube
it's the whole thing
but
sex on a sandbar i remember it flopped
out and hit the sand i put it back in
and she was pissed wow that was an
accident america dude that cures rabies
yeah you know you need a little grit
and uh
so then
we got way too drunk and she had her
mom's car and we were driving back and
we had a friend in the back seat and he
was like gun it got it and she gunned it
and a turn came up out of nowhere and
she flipped the turn the wheel and we
flipped into a ditch
lana you know we're upside down where
you unbuckle the seat belt and you fall
still drunk still drunk oh yeah and it's
dark out and it's in the middle of the
woods
and the cops had to come they had to get
a tow truck to get the car out y'all
couldn't flip it over no no it was like
in that ditch like it would fit in there
like a cookie and a cookie
pin yeah tin
and uh
so the cop came and i remember she was
in a bathing suit still and she was like
you know a hot 16 year old her boob was
out
and you could tell all these fat you
know louisiana cops like ho ho ho
guarantee and they're [ __ ] wiping
their brow like they're putting blush on
yeah yeah they're trying not to but it
was a full nip and she was crying
and they're like they're all hard yeah
they're they're loving it and they're
like oh willie ray get over here get her
information that willy ray's like oh
[ __ ] you watched him notice a tit it was
it was
fun oh we got out of that one but uh
those were those were young days when
you were 16 and just everything just
kind of fell into place it worked out
yeah there was something about the
pressurelessness of that time and i
think it was just
i don't know if that was society i think
it was just that age it was like
like now i think kids are still just
kids that like the phones and stuff is
just part of their thing i think you're
right i think you're right here's what i
hope for
everybody's all you know wokey and
annoying and all that and i think the
kids younger kids see that and of course
they're gonna go the other way yeah so i
think they're gonna rebel against that
and start saying horrible things again
yeah so that's that's my hope
yeah i would like to see a little bit of
it yeah because the awoke thing is just
impossible the end of it is it's uh
there's no end to no end you can't be
good at moral enough
did you see the guy outside of the sonic
the other day who with the the woman or
the man who was saying
they were calling me sir inside and the
guy was like what do you want me to do
you know i'm sorry you know oh no we
bring that up
oh yeah yeah it was this was a hispanic
guy yeah your entire staff has been
calling me sir okay okay uh you wanna
park
i why don't you tell me what we can do
now no because i can do the same thing
with you okay but your entire staff has
been calling me sir the entire time okay
this is obviously me looks like a sir
right now
okay okay
can we please move to the side
no what
look i'm sorry and i apologize for what
happened
okay if they did that or oh i mean uh
why do you want me i'm sorry what else
can i tell you i mean now
what else can i tell you
this guy works at sonic yeah he's
i don't know maybe if they call you a
sir i don't know what they did then
because they saw the name on my credit
card and they were being they were not
being nice people well i mean that's
what your name in the card guy what you
want whether one what do you want them
to tell you right this is a great thing
that has nothing to do with it it does
you don't have any someone in the back
that they don't see
that's paying okay ma'am so why would
they intentionally do that can you tell
me what your location has done to be
transcompetent because clearly they are
not well it's just tough because you're
what he okay they made a mistake and
what should he kill himself like where
do we go from here and you know my name
is mark you call me mike i just i go
yeah how you doing you know like
i get it it's this is important to her
and all that and she's trans and
whatever but like
they [ __ ] up and it's over now and
he's apologized like what else can you
do yeah he goes on to apologize
literally 18 more times and the person
just land back like it just like it's
become this game of like how do i catch
someone to feel that and then and then
that makes you feel some type of way
yeah that's the sick game i think that i
don't understand that much like
this internet game of like who do i how
can i catch like yeah you know who do i
catch with a bag of n words over here
you know or like uh exactly like how can
i go back in your time in your life and
see if you wrote down the n word on a
napkin yeah you know it's just like uh
in the 90s when i it was nobody's
perfect now if it if you're not perfect
we'll figure it out and ruin your life
yeah you know and it's it's weird
because like if you say like [ __ ] or
something they'll come after you and
they go that's him that's where's your
compassion that's so mean to retards and
you're like yeah yeah i get it but
where's your compassion for me [ __ ]
up well i mean
you're you're you can't have it both
ways if you want compassion you got to
be compassionate too
and it's just i'm not yelling it at a
[ __ ] person right i'd never do that
no i'm calling my buddy ernie [ __ ]
yes and we all know ernie's a [ __ ]
target
well we've been around him
exactly you know even as both of his
wives had left him okay
for reasons they didn't want to disclose
in court jerking off with conditioner
which is a child's move yeah come on at
least get the lotion earned just sad to
see yeah you hate to see it and i think
eventually it'll things will flip where
people will turn on that
person person yeah
yeah i think enough so where there's
just like i also think that whole thing
is losing its value you know it's like
um if everything is an 11 nothing is an
11 right
right
but the scary part is when the platforms
that own our ability to communicate
that's when it gets real scary yeah
that's what's going back to corporate
corporations right yeah that's what i
think people were like this person the
president this first president i'm like
att he's the president exactly we owe
them money i don't know buying any money
yeah has given me money actually yeah
dude buy their [ __ ] bro the
government will give anybody money i
know it's the best loan ever does money
it almost doesn't even seem real anymore
sometimes no money is completely just in
up in the air poof you know it's on your
phone you don't see you used to go here
here's 20 bucks and it was 20 and you
earned it yeah there was a thing right
now it's just whoop there you go i just
sent you money like what do you send me
money that's the new normal money has no
value no meaning you used to mow a lawn
and they'd put they put the money in
there put it in your pocket you had a
wallet felt the money and you felt
something like there was a thing like i
did something look what i have exactly
now you can't just you can't even show
it nobody cares there's no no that
doesn't work at a strip club what am i
gonna venmo this skank yeah come on no
you put a dollar bill in there soon yeah
it used to mean something you were
halfway into the panties when you put
that thing in there that was exciting oh
um
do you uh has it been tough for you to
like send your hour with did you wait to
get a whole new hour to go out
uh well i was writing a lot while
having that hour because i was it was
getting embarrassing like i did that
hour for years and i would go to clubs
and go hey i like you man but i came out
last year and did the same [ __ ] and i
was like yeah you're right
well i just like the most prolific i try
to be prolific but i was really trying
to hammer that hour and just really
perfect it and hone it so once i heard
one guy say that it blew my mind and i
changed immediately and just was writing
like a machine but uh
now i have like a new 45 that's not on
anything and it's it's it's cooking yeah
but you always got to have that new
stuff kind of on the back burner yeah
because when you put you're putting out
a thing yeah and are you nervous because
now you're back to zero
yeah i got about yeah i'm doing like 50
minutes right now which is about the
amount of time i do sometimes i'll do up
to an hour but i think sometimes people
also want to go they want to see you
they want to enjoy it they want to go
back home yes um 50 minutes is perfect
but it also depends if the vibe of the
show is going great then it's great yeah
if the vibe's not then i got to grab
some old stuff and kind of put it in you
got that right and uh
and so that definitely gets kind of
scary and i'm just waiting for like
moments that happen where i'm like oh i
found this is good this is good
i can use this this is going to be
perfect you know let's get this uh
let's get this
question right here that came in from
jack harlow
arlo good name jack harlow yeah
uh what's up theo what's up mark uh my
name is tyler from texas um
so there was this hbo show called
talking funny uh
jerry seinfeld chris rock and louis ck
where they sat down for like an hour
long discussion or whatever
and part of that they were talking about
their different methods for building an
hour
for their act or whether maybe it's
going to become a special or whatever
and jerry seinfeld
took the approach of like you take about
remove it and cycle in your new stuff
that way and so over time your act is
this like ever-evolving piece um
i got to see mark a couple months ago
and i kind of noticed something similar
with this material where it's like
there's definitely like uh
staple jokes of yours
um as well as like you trying in the new
stuff and uh this grace that by the way
i was curious is that something that you
picked up from seinfeld that kind of
method of removing a little bit of the
old to push in the new um
or you know what's your general method
for building an hour
um same question theo uh gang gang
thanks guys gang baby i'll let marc
andrew thank you tyler for the for the
question man and for for paying
attention to the show what do you think
more well first of all i can't believe
anybody cares about stand-up who doesn't
do it which is it's i always assume when
we go into stand-up people get bored
yeah but maybe not maybe not this guy's
uh you know at comic-con apparently but
uh
yeah i i i think he nailed it it's just
kind of the natural progression you got
your your pillars like i'll do the the
plant joke and then i'll do the the car
joke and these murder every time so you
you kind of pepper those in like m m's
and trail mix like oh that's the good
stuff
and then you try your new and you got
your your half-baked idea and then when
you start losing them hit them with
another eminem yeah and then you close
with a big eminem at the end but yeah
eventually in natural progression it
will then the new stuff will grow and be
great and then you can just start
letting go of those m m's yeah they just
fluff off and then you got a new hour
but it takes a while
yeah it takes a while it takes a while
and i think that's one thing that's
scary about putting stuff out i think
like i got this special coming out in i
think a week and a half or something but
i'm also sometimes i wish like man i
think the true value would have been in
not putting it out at all
and just touring forever just touring
not just with that material changing my
material
but not having like these definitive
moments where i have to change it the
jay leno method he never put an album
out because he was like i want to keep
this yeah which
i don't know maybe there's good good and
bads to both like if you put this out
it'll force you to write new [ __ ] which
is gonna suck but you have to do it but
if you don't put it out you can just
kind of do it forever and there's no
sometimes we need a deadline as
comedians we're a bunch of lazy cucks
yeah we are kind of huh
i think we can get lazy if we would get
lazy because we knew we're capable of
making things happen at the last minute
exactly exactly that book report man you
would wing that [ __ ] thing dude
wing it bravo one time it was about i
don't know what was about but i remember
taking a bunch of stuff out of our
kitchen and putting it in a bowl and
then putting like this like something on
top of it you had to put your hand in
there and reach in and grab it was like
literally did it in the morning before
school didn't make any sense yeah and
got an a and there'd be like some girl
who'd like made some [ __ ] out of like
right find it or something
and fond it also went to our school dude
find fondant uh
bayham
that was a girl that went to our school
funded yeah the best the best black
names i feel like were in louisiana oh
yeah we had some great ones but then the
last name would be kind of normal it
would be like uh latrine williams yeah
you know bayham washington wilson yes
all presidential yeah yeah yeah go
figure that out yeah that's where you
need to go look if we want to trace some
some lineage of some real shady [ __ ] man
let's start calling out people with the
last name truman okay
that's what i'm saying if there's a
donny truman out there or freaking
randall truman bro we see you fam i know
and george washington must have been
plowing a ton of
afro-americanese because there's so many
are named after him
he was like like banging the whole nba
yeah i know it's unbelievable yeah good
for him
unbelievable but yeah
good for you i can't wait to you got a
title for it or is it a secret it's
called regular people oh all right all
right regular people i can't wait to
watch because i love a special because
you get that intro you get the crowd i
get to see all i've never seen your
whole hour yeah so i'm excited to watch
thanks man
yeah and yours people can watch it if
they haven't seen it it's on youtube you
got that right um
yeah a lot of ways real envious man just
the fact that you still own it man
that's real there's so much there's
something about that
for me that's like the biggest thing i
feel like yeah yeah i could do do
anything i could sell it to lithuania
television or some [ __ ] right you know
gotta get a couple paychecks off of it
but it's nice i can chop it up
i can do whatever i want with it it's
nice to own yeah because netflix i mean
look we all love netflix but they own
your [ __ ] and you get one check and
that's it yeah
it's kind of scary no residuals no
nothing yeah it's a little scary man
it's a little scary and then also the
way that things can just disappear right
there that things can just disappear so
easily on netflix whereas i feel like if
you get
a hint of you
on youtube say somebody watches a clip
of you and i right
yep then there's a chance they're going
to get served this
whereas on youtube on netflix right
i'm not in a bunch of stuff on netflix
so it's not like you're going to see me
and then they're going to say suggest
this yeah and if you don't get suggested
something
there's you never find it it's over
netflix is a real grab bag you know
what's weird about netflix too is you go
to your friend's house and you're
scrolling through his you're like
none of these shows are on mine what the
hell is all this yeah cause they put you
in this algo and then you've got a whole
different algo yeah it's weird it's like
going through your friend's cupboard
you're like damn i never heard of uh you
know
twisty fruits yeah but that's in your
world and you go back to my world and
it's cocoa puffs yeah
yeah it's like we're all in different
algorithms but there's not that it's
like
um
that's the thing we're all falling into
these algorithms that's the president's
man those are the presidents of the
corporations man it really is that's it
yeah it's like it's gonna become like oh
we were algorithm buddies or something
like that's gonna be a term one day yeah
like dude we were freaking algo babies
we you know both of our moms are in the
same algorithm yeah that's true like let
me read your algorithm somebody will
literally
read someone's algorithm and predict
their future which will be so easy to do
yeah
they said uh sam harris said your phone
knows you're gay before you do wow and
it's true because it'll notice like oh
you stopped on this uh hot guy picture
for longer than you stopped on the hot
girl or whatever so yeah maybe you'll
decorate your room with this pink sea
salt huh yeah exactly
and uh
my girl
she you know it's hard to buy presents
for your girlfriend because you don't
know what the hell they want and you
don't want to [ __ ] it up
but her phone goes you'll like this and
i'm like i need to get in tune with her
phone to know what the the gift is yeah
the phone knows her better than i know
her
i can't get her off yeah oh yeah that
vibration though she puts it down there
and calls herself
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
let's look at uh let's get a couple more
questions that came in from mark man and
then we'll send him on his way
you got a handsome fan base i got to
tell you oh thank you man yeah we got a
lot of great people man we got a lot of
great people just hit the road dude it's
so crazy to see people come out isn't
that crazy to see people start to come
out crazy and you want to give everybody
their time oh you want to give everybody
it's like you want to thank it's like
you want to thank them so much
you just
oh it's hard and it feels exhausting
yeah yeah
you're like i've been waiting so i've
been trying my since i was [ __ ] nine
years old yeah to make you laugh and
finally here you and i are yeah
totally and then then you go hide in the
green room yeah yeah this is the
weirdest
weirdest thing but that's how it is
look at the guy theo mark what's up boys
how's it going uh theo saw you out in
cedar rapids last year uh killer show
and it was great meeting you man mark
long time listener at tuesdays with
stories love the pod
um my question for you guys is what's
the craziest heckler story you've ever
had and i'm not talking just like you
know some banter back and forth i'm
talking about like got pissed rush the
stage etc um i've never heard that asked
on here before and i just wanted to know
thanks guys love you both
cheers brother thank you
that's a classic
that's a good one you got one well i've
had so many bad heckles uh but the one
that really [ __ ] me up was
i was doing a i was kind of new i was
probably like three four years in i got
a college gig which was huge yeah good
money fly you down put you up
and i was in florida and it was called
florida atlantic it was an all-black
school which i didn't know but i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah so i show up and i had
to follow a rap group it was like kind
of a talent night
i had to follow a rap group and they
were like
twirling shirts going kill whitey you
[ __ ] the cops i'll kill you you know
[ __ ] this [ __ ] or whatever and they're
killing like the whole place is jumping
yeah yeah it was the dnc basically yeah
yeah
and uh i remember there was like a
little cute nerdy black girl with a
clipboard going okay you're next and i
just want to let you know it's very
diverse like it's not diverse it's all
black i'm the diversity
but whatever
so
it was me and this other kid and we were
both supposed to do 30 minutes
so uh you know these people don't want
30 minutes of one guy so he goes up
first and they trash him immediately and
he gets off after like a minute and a
half and i was like
what are you crazy you got to do your
time at least so he's like [ __ ] this i'm
out of here i'm calling my agent he was
like a
he had self-esteem this guy oh yeah yeah
yeah so then i'm like all right and then
they bring me up like oh we got another
live one coming up oh baby and then he's
looking at me like oh this guy's a goner
like i totally set up for failure
so i walk on stage and i'm walking to
the mic the mic is like right where that
camera is and i haven't gotten there yet
and some guy goes look at this [ __ ]
kills kills
huge laugh so i was like all right all
right i can handle this so i was in such
a new york state of mind i was like damn
man what if i was actually gay and he
goes no no you are
that got an applause break he's getting
high five they're crowd surfing this guy
he's a hero and then i try to do 20
minutes uh on uber after that and they'd
i just ate my lunch for half an hour but
i did my time
yes yeah but it was brutal man that was
a i was just watching my watch tick
long half hour long 30.
like the irishman why do you think oh
the irishman's unbelievably bad it's so
long doesn't even make any [ __ ] that
or the party whatever i don't know the
difference between the two the [ __ ]
shit's horrible
you know what i'm saying dude yeah some
of it's so [ __ ] bad
um i would rather watch that guy sheamus
from wwe wrestle that seems more
authentic
to the irish mafia
um
but dude why is it that comedians can
take that [ __ ] what that thing
because that's for some people that
would kill them that would put them into
a mental breakdown that's true i think
cause we have our me our mind is already
so mean to us so we're like oh i can
handle this and they were kind of
laughing so in a weird way i was like
they're trashing me i'm the punching bag
but at least i'm creating entertainment
even though i am the butt of the joke
we're all having a good time i mean i'm
not but they are right so there's a part
of me like at least this is kind of
fun for them
but it was it was harsh
yeah even though i'm the butt of the
joke at least they're having a good time
yeah like if i wasn't there they
wouldn't be laughing right and it's
they're mocking me and it hurt but at
least i'm a part of something yeah
so i i took it
yeah man i uh i have one like that
university of north florida they booed
us off this they booed me off the stage
they didn't know how to come back out in
florida yeah they didn't know i had to
come back out between each it was a
battle of the bands
oh yeah they know how to come back out
again between each band i burned all my
supposed to do five minutes with each
band right i told him i had 40 minutes
bro i had [ __ ] 18 minutes
i burned it all out the first time and i
had to come back out [ __ ] like six
more times oh my god you just gotta
start riffing what is that a clock over
there holy hell oh it became a running
gag when i ran at least about the third
time the fourth time it was like no way
this dude's back
i actually physically became the joke
there was one time and they used to have
this room in la called um
[Music]
it was like at a bar cafe in ucla and
westwood
it was like uh
college kids are ruthless yeah and it
was ucla bar so there's no
chick it's a it's a sad environment
like compared to what college most
college kids are used to yeah
so
one kid starts tackling me in the
awnings dude he's talking [ __ ] right i
got just lost it man i get off stage i'm
coming at the dude start choking him
what yeah choking the guy wow i really
had the mic in my hand the whole time
i'm choking him right yeah ah you could
hear the swallowing oh yeah you could
hear it all it's crazy and i'm like why
were you being so mean to me just the
[ __ ] lamest thing you can say to
somebody yeah
but that was that and people were dying
laughing because he and i are tussling
but the mic is right there good for you
but i had one similar hartford funny
bone this is years ago it's probably
like
25 people in the room i'm eating my ass
this guy is in the front row i'm talking
a real nerd guy like a fat guy with
glasses and a beard and he had
a woman with him
and another like a sister and his cousin
or something and he's just this guy is
like a loser and i'm bombing and they
keep doing the thing where they mimic my
bomb like i'd be like oh mick ultra huh
that's the punch i need to go mick ultra
that was bad and then i'd be like well
what about a shag carpet he's like shrek
carpet nothing there you know and it was
no one could hear it but me so he was
like taunting me so i just lost it on
this guy and i was like [ __ ] you you
piece of [ __ ] and apparently he was like
kind of downsy or something so maybe he
was not [ __ ] with me maybe he was
just being [ __ ] or something and i
but i didn't know that i kept going at
him and
this is when it gets really bad when
you're like [ __ ] you and i just got
angry it wasn't even funny and this guy
in the back goes go easy on him so i go
well [ __ ] you too what the hell i'm up
here alone blah blah blah
so eventually the guy
got up the the [ __ ] guy got up and
was like what the [ __ ] i was like oh
[ __ ] this guy's all you know a little
little melted and i was like oh [ __ ]
all right well what are you gonna do and
they threw the kid out and they had to
throw him out and like he was like kind
of moaning and stuff oh it was bad
and then i had i had like another 20 to
do after that it was a nightmare so now
the other crowd hates me because i
i [ __ ] on them it was going to hell man
yeah i didn't know i didn't know you
didn't know and that look i had the same
thing happen man um that's a very good
story and it's better than mine but i'm
still going to tell mine please i'm in
san francisco and it's at like a weed
conference or something right and i
don't even smoke weed so i'm at the
place people are blowing weed smoke in
the air and stuff and so i start getting
just exuded out on stage bro there's a
guy dressed it's like the san francisco
weed conference or just some some
some
it was bad yeah
um pre-legal or or legalized it's
pre-legal okay so we were still a big
deal there were like booths there was
like thc stuff but it was still they
were pushing the limits right and some
guy was dressed like a captain like a
total captain brings me on stage at that
point i am so cooked out of my gizzard
like the whole people just been blowing
joints it's the i'm the last act of the
day it's been an all-day affair uh-huh
there's probably 13 people in a room
that would seat maybe 150. oh boy all
these folding chairs
the guy in the front is mentally
disabled right nobody tells me yeah
nobody tells me i get up there i didn't
eat i literally didn't even know what
was going on i didn't know that i was a
comedian i didn't know what was
happening oh you were that high i don't
know if i was an auctioneer i didn't
know what was happening
it was not good right and this guy
starts saying stuff messing with me
and um
finally somebody yells out could have
even been you yells out that guy's
[ __ ] right
and i was like well put a sign on him
then you know right that's a good line
and then finally
it was the first last time
[Music]
and i quit i got down i was like i'm
done i think it had literally been four
minutes dude
but when you're high four minutes is
like a week i think everybody the guy
there was like man you did great dude
you did great you paid me my money
all right unless i have to be an agent
yeah they paid me a thousand
bucks that's big
that was big not a bad gig just trash
this uh downsy kid and get a check yeah
could be worse
i think it was bobby a bear so i think
it was yeah oh deep cut he passed away
didn't he yeah he did god that was crazy
in new orleans he was every mom's hunk
like he was like the guy all the moms
like camilla red beans yeah yeah
i love to have the coach for kids that k
like you don't need a coat in new
orleans like we're doing coats for kids
every time we kick a field goal we get
every kit every kid gets a coach you
thought about that you're right it was
like who needs a cup of code a meal yeah
i'm gonna hug
i saw morris bart was still going yeah
it's crazy is he really yeah i see the
the billboard he runs that town wow i'm
on your side one call that's all chip
for stall you ever see that oh he takes
care of it yeah how about a step that
used to work for him door
furniture or 1825
too lane wow now we're doing local
commercials yeah that was fun though and
remember they had uh morgan's presents
did you ever see that yes yes that was
big chopsley
let's get a picture of it so yeah
this was pre-internet entertainment bro
you know who you got to go see suicide
boys man who's that they're this new
orleans like uh
they have they're this new orleans
it's kind of a rack rap rock it's their
own thing man really yeah they're great
though yeah let's see morgan's presents
this was like pbs in that picture what
do you call it public access
yeah i didn't i had to leave new orleans
to realize it was a small town
yeah
yeah you didn't realize when you got
somewhere else you're like oh they don't
even have that yeah exactly yeah
yeah louisiana was nice that was one
thing that was nice about everything
kind of had their own shows every area
in town had their own things yep that's
another thing that's kind of a bummer
about everything getting so
commercialized just so
like you know
there's just no more like small chains
it's just all of it kind of goes by the
wayside yeah yeah remember like getting
a job at the at the row bears i was a
bad boy like that's over
i don't we went christmas caroling we
went uh trick-or-treating it just feels
like that's all kind of
old now antiquated yeah it feels like
some things are just uh
like some of the fabric of society has
come unwoven i completely agree and i
don't know
how and why and it makes you feel like
your life doesn't mean as much because
you had really invested in kind of the
template of what
everything was you know yeah now meaning
is clicks and followers and likes and
now everything is race like every book
now is like why this was racist
yeah it's just like you know frederick
douglass was racist i saw the other day
a book really i'm like what damn
what it how what like when is that gonna
end i know wow yeah well it's like you
said you got to have a gotcha on
somebody it's like a kill
you know yeah and you want a big kill
you want to take down uh
louie or whoever it's gotta be a big
kill
yeah yeah it's tough you know
nobody wants to build you they just want
to tear down [ __ ] now right
it's way easier it is way easier
yeah we got to fight we got to do our
best man it's hard sometimes yeah
i think we're out there i think people
like us who just kind of want to
live and have relationships and uh
connect i think we're out there yeah i
think that's the majority actually i do
too i think that a lot of those people
probably there's just not they're just
not busy doing all of that [ __ ] that
other people are doing yeah yeah and
that's way healthier yeah it is you know
sometimes you're on twitter and you just
get wrapped up in the [ __ ] then i go see
my brother he's got two kids and he's
pushing him on a swing and yeah i'm like
oh yeah he's not thinking about this no
he's worried about his kids getting uh
pudding yeah
yeah most people are living yeah when
you get outside of this most people are
living in a pretty regular universe man
yeah yeah we just we can't forget that
um let's get this last question that
came in here mark and we'll send you on
your way you got how many shows you got
this weekend five six six
three on saturday two tomorrow one
sunday is this your first time doing
three shows in a night no no i've been
doing that a while but if you want to
pop by i don't know if you're busy um no
pressure i appreciate it i am you you
have one on sunday too yeah
maybe
maybe i'll try to make that one no
pressure because i got uh i'm heading
out of town tomorrow oh okay
bye
what's up guys my name is jake i'm out
here in houston mark i saw you last time
you were out here is a great show
traveling like y'all do
i'm wondering
what's the weirdest proposition that
you've gotten from a fan
not like uh come to my hotel room come
to the bar
thinking more like
have you ever gotten something like
someone's like come to my apartment and
bottle feed me there's something weird
anyways and i'm just curious
would an animal even ask you that
interesting that's a good question i've
had definitely had the swingers like hey
we swing if you're interested blah blah
but uh the craziest thing was one guy
was like i live out on a lake in a
cabbage a cabin
i try to say cabin and cottage and i
said cabbage but uh
lived on a cabin in the lake and he's
like come out here
i'll pick you up from the airport it's
like a three-hour drive fly in early
we'll fish we'll grill it up we'll watch
movies and i'm like
dude this is a lot i wouldn't do this
with my my
aunt right and you want me to do it i've
never met you you know and i i know they
listen a lot of pods so they think they
know you but i'm like that sounds like a
nightmare yeah
but
yes extensive people offer you extensive
things come in a few days earlier yeah
you know let's live it up man yeah we'll
do something chill man we'll get a
bounce house right right you know we hit
the grocery you're like this is sounding
this is too intimate yeah it's too some
of it's too intimate yeah and it's nice
you're like oh that's sweet but i would
that would be work
yeah just the car ride from the airport
to your three-hour cabin is like damn
what are we gonna talk about
that's a lot yeah
so yeah the [ __ ] like that is tough but
it's also flattering
right yeah it is flattering that
somebody would be brave enough to spend
that much time with you
yeah exactly and then i think i'm kind
of jealous because i would assume no one
would want to hang out with me but
they're like oh he'll want to go right
i'm like what kind of mindset is that do
you think people want to go hang out
with you yeah
and then your time gets so busy you're
doing the shows because people want to
see the show right but then you don't
have as much free time as you used to
exactly and then you got to do your gym
you got to do your your solo pod or
whatever it is so
it's all such a
it's life man this is where we are yeah
yeah and it could be worse oh yeah i
know yeah and i'm not complaining i'm
just trying to examine it yeah and
sometimes the examination is um
you know you have to just be honest
about the examination even if
uh
even whether things are going good or
not good you still want to try and get a
be able to look at things yeah you're
here you gotta what do you call that
dissect and analyze all the time yeah
yeah man we're just a couple of
formaldehyde frogs out here man oh you
got that right boy remember that [ __ ]
where you cut that open and collapse oh
yeah and try to get the hot girl in your
group but then you realized how gross it
was what you were doing yeah yeah
that was better though cause at least
you weren't
writing or reading you know it was weird
to cut up on that pig but it broke up
the day a little bit yeah it was kind of
an ice breaker too
my teacher remember was dipping when we
did that oh yeah yeah that was some real
louisiana [ __ ] we had a teacher that got
busted from
homosexuality actually but uh that was a
crime
but
he uh his replacement came in during the
pig cutting so like second day of pig
heading we got a new guy damn and it's
this bald-headed huge guy
and he literally was drinking a [ __ ]
like four gallon jug of kombucha
mushroom juice and no one had ever heard
of it and he's like i'm telling you this
[ __ ] will save lives and we're like this
guy's [ __ ] insane
he just starts eating the pig
that's crazy bro the pig he touches and
they start coming back to life
but it blew our minds and we'd never
heard of it and then for 10 years i
didn't hear it right and then it was
like the biggest thing in the world but
this dude i gotta find that guy and
figure out how did he learn about that
let's get him on the pod because that
dude was sipping heavy yeah i did
shrooms last night yeah yeah how was the
experience good i love shrimp i think
it's the best drug yeah it's a popular
drug man um i've thought about uh using
it to try and get off of antidepressants
you know doing the micro reducing the
microwave it works it helps the euphoria
yeah i've had friends that have had
success with it um
because i'm sick of being addicted to
like just like even antidepressants like
i started taking these [ __ ] a day
like i don't even know what i'm like
yeah am i better i know
every doctor you guys see they're just
like oh just keep taking them you're
taking them just keep taking them see
that's scary yeah but you seem fine i
mean i don't know what's going on in the
in the personal life but i feel okay i
think i just uh but you wonder like how
long
you know yeah does it ever click and you
go i don't need them anymore right my
dad was the scary dad growing up you
know big forearms and he gave you one of
these
scary dad and he started taking
antidepressants when i was in college
rheya sunshine wow so weird he's like
how are you he changes his tone and
everything and you're like you know you
still flinch because he was so scary but
uh it it 180 them totally different guy
damn it's weird it's almost kind of like
who's this guy right that's the thing
yeah you're like sometimes that's like i
feel like i um like there's thoughts and
ideas and like sometimes i think because
of in relationships i'm unable to
connect sometimes i think sometimes i'm
not able to have certain feelings yeah
because the medicine kind of just leaves
you in the middle yes so it's like you
don't really get the
feelings you need to create love which
are highs and lows i think the high
level norm always said that he was
wildly depressed and people say you want
some pills he said no i you got to
experience the whole thing even though
it sucks
yeah
well we're out here experiencing it man
um out to lunch right you got it you can
check out the special on youtube please
go check it out if you haven't and uh
mark norman touring and changing his
life dude and owning his stuff while he
does it man you got that right you got
to own like slavery yeah
if it even happened that's true i think
it's a hoax they never found the boats
you know
um
the holocaust wasn't real that's uh
uh mark norman ladies and gentlemen
thanks for coming man hey thanks for
having me good to be here fatty praise
allah i'll see you on the
that's good road hey all right fun app